i'm sure you've noticed our southern
border has been a mess all year nearly
two point uh 2.2 million illegals that
means the ones we found let alone the
got aways are crossing already this year
and it's not over but vice president
kamala harris is once again nowhere to
be found this is her job and even
democrats are upset about it case in
point texas congressman henry cuellar
quoted today saying that he recently
revealed that he called the vp this
summer to offer advice on border issues
he's from a border state and a border
city but he never heard back they're in
the same party the congressman went on
to say that she doesn't see she seems
uninterested and he kind of gave up on
her he said i moved past her well
apparently griping to the new york times
she didn't stop yet about her boss her
media coverage and her role in the white
house all in today's uh today's paper
the article published today reads like
this while most of the pres while most
presidents promise their vice
president's access and influence at the
end of the day power responsibility are
not shared equally and mr biden does not
always feel a need for input from miss
harris as he navigates some of the most
important relationships so kamala harris
feels like she's being left out and
she's speaking out but it wasn't always
like this at the beginning of the
administration she was side by side with
the president for every public
appearance and we can't forget she was
the last one of the room when the
president decided to pull out of
afghanistan and that went really well it
looked like things started out great so
what went wrong and why is kamala harris
struggling so badly and talking about it
we're going to ask two people that know
quite well in fact the new york times
article reads like this miss harris had
privately told her allies that the news
coverage of her would be different if
she were any of her 48 predecessors who
are all white all male joining us right
now to react fox news contributor former
president
bush's deputy chief of staff karl rove
and former white house press secretary
host of a co-host of outnumbered
and this brand new book that's a
bestseller for such a time as this
kaylee mcinnini kaylee let's uh let's
start with you were you stunned to see
this because clearly this is a strategy
she talked to the la times the san
francisco chronicle cbs television and
then this story
well i'll say i was stunned when the
first cnn hit peace and yeah i just said
that the right way cnn hit peace against
kamala harris you know you have an issue
when cnn is coming out against you or at
least their reporting is cnn had three
dozen sources citing the dysfunction in
kamala harris's office this article in
the new york times again a liberal
publication had two dozen sources but
what was so instructive to me in this
piece brian
is the opening anecdote where they talk
about joe manchin coming into the white
house the west wing about to go into the
oval office and apparently kamala harris
is there with joe biden and rather than
bringing kamala into the meeting uh they
he says to her you know give a smile i'm
paraphrasing here say hello to joe
manchin um and then she goes back to her
office and she felt sidelined and the
resulting headline was you know we need
kamala to win not necessarily to govern
but what's interesting to me is while
kamala may see that anecdote and say i'm
being sidelined there's a reason at the
heart of this why this happened it's her
incompetence it's because she went out
on west virginia airwaves and lashed out
at joe manchin a rookie move no one
would ever suggest a vice president do
but she did so the point of the story is
she feels sidelined but it's really her
own incompetence at the heart of why she
feels that way carl could you bring me
inside the white house if this came out
and let's say it was dick cheney saying
it or a key staffer saying it the white
house has to address this correct don't
you think there's been a phone call or a
visit already
i suspect there's been a conversation
between the white house chief of staff
and the chief of staff for the vice
president
but this is highly unusual um i i don't
remember this happening
under president trump under president
obama it certainly didn't happen under
president bush i don't remember it
happening under
his predecessor bill clinton or
bush 41 or ronald reagan this is we're
seeing something play out here that's
highly unusual and i think it goes to
kaylie's point she wouldn't be getting
criticized if she were competent and
take immigration rather than be involved
in the real immigration problem the
problem that representative cuellar was
calling her about namely two million
plus people coming across our south
southern border and straining federal
and state and local resources to the
stretch and stretching them to the limit
and beyond instead what she says her
problem her her responsibility is to
deal with the immigration the thrust for
immigration coming from the triangle
guatemala honduras and nicaragua is not
to be dealing with what's happening on
our southern border so she's been
defining herself out of the real
problems and if you're not dealing with
the real problems people are going to
look at you and say are you up to the
job yeah she complained about her
portfolio and she never attacked her
portfolio she gave they said i don't
like the jobs i was given essentially
karen bass went to bat for two against
the president so good luck with that
meanwhile this story came out i want you
to comment on kaylee and here's an
excerpt from it in politico about the
morale in the white house quote in the
first year of the biden white house
camaraderie has been fleeting and many
teams are suffering from low morale
according to several officials many are
also currently eyeing the exits creating
the potential for a higher than usual
turnover
for the beginning of a at the end of one
year and the beginning of the next and
it turns out the politico said they
these staffers reached out to them
kaylee
yeah
yeah that's right look we had a lot of
leaks in the trump white house i think
it's something that's regrettable i yeah
i don't think it's productive for any
younger staffer to leak against a white
house you want to be on board you need a
team that's rolling forward for the
american people so i hate to see this
happening for biden like it did for
trump but i do think it indicates
something big going on here they're
talking to politico playbook a lot of
these staffers
and they feel left out they feel
marginalized they feel they haven't had
a staff meeting until there was a fire
drill at the white house and they were
all congregated outside i was in the
white house during covet 19. mark
meadows every single monday had a
meeting where we all went in
together and we talked through the
issues and that was during the height of
the pandemic i get there are unique
circumstances but you got to have
meetings like that even if they're on
the phone there's a year where we had
covet on the downturn they should have
been having these meetings and that's
the reason i think for a lot of the
leaking right it's pretty uh pretty uh
interesting carl this is what they said
uh some staffers say it's the result of
an insular top-heavy white house of
long-time biden aides who are distant
from much of the staff no new friends in
biden world final thought
yeah the senate
the senate aides surround former senator
joe biden and that is a problem because
the white house is is
more effective when it has clear
communications up and down and there
there is an insular nature of this white
house it affects not only the the the
the morale of the war of the working
staff of the white house it also affects
the quality of the president's direction
and his leadership because they're not
listening they're not reaching out and
they're they're re they're waiting for
their guidance from him rather than
helping him shape the right decisions
this is the biggest surprise for me i
thought they'd get this stuff set and
maybe the policies we'd be debating but
we could they can't get their playbook
and they can't get everyone to line up
the right way uh hey kaylee mcinerney
karl rove your mission now is to have a
great christmas thanks so much
merry christmas to you all right back at
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else